hi I'm Christopher Hine and today I'm
making a supplemental video talking
about something that I'm working on
currently um which is called the concept
of index um that is a term for me I've
only recently started using it a lot
although I've been playing with this
concept a lot I just didn't really have
a good term for it basically the index
and I'm stealing it from the German
indis which um is used in swordfighting
to explain um the moment of of contact
and I'm using it in that way which is um
when I catch some someone in their cycle
of movement and you might be familiar
with this through Japanese martial arts
of the concept of s no send no s and go
no s but I think there's more to talk
about and I think it can be outlined a
little differently than those Concepts
and so I'm going to explain a little bit
about how I explain that day I'm gonna
get Josh out here we're gonna go to work
Josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so today we're going to talk a
little bit about index uh this thing
that I'm working with which kind of
comes from an idea I learned in German
long swword and also it really stood out
to me because those ideas are are are
echoed in Japanese swordsmanship with
the concept of sen no s sen no and
Goosen and I think there's a little bit
more to be explored in that area uh
we're going to do a weapon practice here
to kind of show you so I'm going to show
you a really basic uh iido technique
that you see all the time in the forums
although it's kind of sometimes hard to
realize if Josh and I were both in ski
Kamai here and Josh were to transition
jodan guch to hit me right okay so let's
actually go ahead and switch positions
here so I can face the camera okay so
we're here like this and Josh
transitions Jordan gu shoe to hit me
okay now why he would do that there's
many reasons as to why he could do that
he might might do that because um I have
gotten far away so maybe he was striking
at me and I'm I'm really trying to push
back and so he's covering that distance
to come in and hit me he could be doing
it because I'm charging him and he's
back stepping to get out of the way of
that that hit right so he's trying to
use the length Advantage he has in that
position over this one so you see it in
the forms all the time you might not
recognize it but that little piece is in
a ton of the forms uh and in the aama
system constant constant constant okay
now we got to understand what's
happening when Josh decides to do that
there's a whole bunch of stuff that's
going on one is in his mind he has got
the idea that that's a good move for
whatever reason because I'm backing up
or because I'm coming in okay then he
has to start the action so the start of
the action's like right there right
that's the start of the action he's
begun the action then he has to deliver
the action and then there's the
conclusion of the action right so that's
the conclusion of the action so all that
stuff has to happen every time he wants
to do something right he doesn't just
think something in his head and then
instantly it happens now there's a
moment that I catch him in that right so
meaning that I could say Josh has the
intent to come and hit me and I go boom
right so on his intent to hit me I hit
him before he can do anything right
that's one index is Josh's intent went
somewhere and I caught the intent okay
could be that Josh has begun his action
and I go boom right and I come in there
and I get him so I caught him the index
was right there when he started his
action could be Josh is in the middle of
delivery boom right okay could be that
Josh has completed his action boom and
there are different answers I'll have
and different things that I need to do
for each and every one of those and
depending on where I catch him I'll have
a different set of answers so it's
important to understand that you know
when we're looking at forms we're
looking kind of at snapshots of things
but there's a whole giant gray area in
between so let's say I caught him at the
first index so Josh has the intent he
hasn't even begun to move yet and I'm so
quick I can get in here now look I'm in
between his arms so if Josh goes to
transition into anything else right I
can work with his arms and I can move
him wherever I want so that's the next
set of skills on that right let's say
Josh starts to come in I hit him here
before he's even developed into the
second part of the Starke I'm probably
going to blast him and he's going to fly
away and I won't have to even deal with
him because I hit him at just the right
cycle okay let's say he's a little
further in delivery there and I hit him
here I'm almost certainly going to have
to cover my head after I hit because
he's far enough forward that even after
I hit him he's probably going to fold
and hit me anyways okay could be that I
can't even get in there and then I'm
certainly going to have to cover my head
and defend myself okay so you can see
this kind of practice echoed in uh sin
no go no and sin no uh and you can see
this practice um echoed in uh the VOR
the indis and the no if you say German
German work um but the idea is that
there's an index of time and in this
index of time all all kinds of different
stuff can be happening but I think just
being aware that this exists will kind
of help you understand the forms in a
whole new light I'm Christopher Hine
this is Joshua TI my salon McDaniel is
behind that camera right over there all
right thanks a lot for watching
[Music]